initially tunic looks like little more
than a reverential homage to the legend
of zelda its isometric viewpoint might
skew from the top down perspective used
in early zelda games like a link to the
past but the other similarities will be
immediately familiar to anyone who's
ever embarked on a hyrulian adventure
before both link and tunic's adorable
fox protagonist have a proclivity for
wielding a sword and shield while
donning green clothing and exploring all
manner of abandoned temples and dense
woodland tunic's first 30 or so minutes
do little to dispel the comparisons
gradually however this begins to change
before long you'll find yourself
desperately fighting to survive emerging
from tense and engaging battles with
only a sliver of health left all while
uncovering the compellingly obstructed
secrets of this mysterious world as it
turns out tunic has less in common with
zelda than it initially seems instead
it's a genuine souls-like
[Music]
combat might capture the familiar look
and feel of lynx fisticuffs the camera
zooms in as you lock on and swing your
sword from side to side to vanquish your
foes but it's all stamina based amir
determines how often you can roll out of
danger and absorb damage with your
shield before being knocked back leaving
you wide open to a devastating counter
attack managing your stamina is key to
staying alive since once the meter runs
dry any wounds you sustain do 50 more
damage than they usually would
fortunately attacking doesn't consume
any of your stamina it only halts the
refilling process creating a compelling
incentive to be proactive when the
situation calls for it there are a
variety of enemy types too each with
their own unique attack patterns and
defensive maneuvers learning their
routines and knowing when to attack
dodge and block becomes the core of
tunic's combat it's all fairly
simplistic on the surface with one
button used to perform a basic three-hit
combo but when you're in the heat of
battle forced to manage groups of
diverse enemies despite your ever
dwindling stamina meter it's
nail-bitingly tense and ultimately
rewarding when you manage to emerge
victorious
[Music]
[Music]
like other games in the genre tunic is
punishingly difficult while this is
partly due to how demanding its combat
often is it's also because it adopts a
familiar structure to from software's
games as you explore tunic's varied
world you'll discover shrines that
refill your health bar and replenish
your healing items the catch is that
resting at these strands also respawns
all of the enemies you may have
previously defeated falling in battle
will return you to the last run you
visited costing you all of your
accumulated wealth unless you can return
to the site of your death and recover it
before perishing again this is all
derivative of course but this structure
works in tunic's favor knowing you could
lose all of your precious upgrade
materials because of a fatal mistake in
combat increases the tension of each
fight just as discovering a new shrine
is uplifting after venturing through a
lengthy dungeon the level design is also
excellent with shortcuts hidden
throughout its interconnected world and
labyrinthine dungeons cleverly obscured
by the game's isometric point of view
boss fights are a particular highlight
too demanding a proficiency of tunic's
combat while increasing the sense of
scale to make for some truly spectacular
battles you'll be ducking and weaving
between scything blows from a ruined
sentry using your shield to block a
scavenger's rifle fire and clashing
swords with an ethereal figure one of
the key areas where tunic deviates from
the souls like genre is by adding a
couple of difficulty options by entering
the game's accessibility menu you can
choose to either remove the stamina
mechanic altogether so you can attack
and defend at infinitum or turn on god
mode so you can never die and this
doesn't disable achievements either
although both options alter the game
considerably they hope to remove the
barrier to entry if you're interested in
tunic but don't want to get stuck on an
insurmountable boss or a particularly
tough dungeon you can turn both options
on or off at any time as well making
them a perfect way to get through the
game's most trying moments they're not
something you should lean on straight
away since they do impact the
satisfaction of combat by removing much
if not all of the challenge but if you
want to see the game through to its
conclusion and can't it's worth tying
around with these options however none
of the difficulty options help when it
comes to tunic's over opaqueness from
the game's earliest moments you're given
no direction and all of the signposts
use language that you don't understand
to make sense of where you are and what
you're supposed to do next you'll need
to find the lost pages of an instruction
manual scattered throughout the world
these pages are utterly fantastic both
in their execution and ingenuity each
one looks like it was pulled from an
instruction manual from the early 90s
complete with coffee stains and
handwritten notes presumably from the
person who rented the game before you
they're still mostly in this obscure
language so you'll have to interpret
what they're telling you by the images
and few recognizable words that exist in
a lot of ways it's reminiscent of
flipping through the pages of an
instruction booklet from an imported
game trying to decipher its mechanics
when you can't read japanese i didn't
initially realize the importance of
these pages until it was too late for my
own good after throwing myself at the
first boss over 20 different times i
defeated the mechanized pain in the neck
only to discover the instruction
manual's page of contents with this in
hand i noticed that one of the pages i'd
already collected was titled increasing
your power which detailed how some of
the items i found weren't used to
provide temporary buffs like originally
thought but could be used in conjunction
with tunic's currency to permanently
upgrade various attributes at any of the
game's shrines with increased health bar
improved defense and a more potent
attack the first boss's sudden
difficulty spike made a lot more sense
don't get me wrong tunic is still
challenging but you can at least keep up
with the power curve when you know how
to decipher this meta game layer with
this knowledge in my possession i
started paying closer attention to each
of the pages i uncovered most of them
display maps for the various locations
you'll visit while others offer combat
tips and enemy descriptions the most
interesting pages however delve into
tunic's many secrets by offering subtle
hints and clues figuring out these
conundrums is particularly rewarding not
least because it means you'll be
exploring every nook and cranny of
tunic's gorgeous environments much of
the game looks completely tactile almost
like it's an extravagant diorama grass
and bushes are reminiscent of foam
gently wobbling from side to side when
you brush by and many of its structures
appear as though they were molded from
clay the overall art style is
simultaneously simple and detailed with
modern effects like realistic lighting
and shadows all the way water reflects
off walls in the sewer adding a
contemporary edge to an aesthetic that's
otherwise evocative of the 16-bit era
these secrets and tunic's level design
art style and pacing capture a fantastic
sense of discovery and wonder that could
be because you figured out how to
teleport to a looming tower that
features a boss battle on its roof high
above the clouds used a classic cheat
code to open a locked door that's been
bugging you for hours or descended into
the murky underground depths where
reanimated skeletons and magic welding
frogs rule the roost the only downside
to exploration is that fast travel is
oddly restrictive which makes returning
to previously visited areas and
searching for secrets more arduous than
it should be it's also somewhat common
to find yourself stuck behind obstacles
requiring a restart to the beginning of
the area a few blemishes aside the eight
year wait for tunic has been completely
worth it if you could lay out all the
pieces separately like a broken puzzle
each one might seem derivative however
when you put all the pieces together to
create a full picture they make for a
game that's quite unlike anything else
most cells like tend to adopt a grim
dark fantasy aesthetic but tunic harkens
back to the 8 and 16 bit errors by
presenting a vibrant and colorful world
that also offers a fiendishly difficult
challenge it's not simply evocative of
games from the late 80s and early 90s
because it creates facsimiles of their
graphics or gameplay but because it
managed to capture the tangible feeling
of exploration and difficulty where an
instruction manual is your tool to
deciphering everything it's the kind of
game you would have purchased because
the box heart looked cool eagerly
flipping through the pages of its manual
on the car ride home not quite
understanding it all but getting excited
at the possibilities all the same in
tune's case this grand adventure lives
up to the expectation
you